[Music]
there's one thing I know this is not the
last we will hear from a de box is that
how you're feeling right now what's
going through your head it's not the
last you will hear of a devoxx you said
it the right way baby right after I get
off for this Idol train I am ready to
work I'm gonna get home and I am going
to start writing songs keep writing
songs and they start booking gigs I have
so much stuff planned for the future and
y'all just wait in the next couple years
y'all are gonna see something bigger
than American Idol could ever have
created here's the thing I asked you
this last week you know American Idol is
a show that's been around a long time in
this season for the first time we saw
people of different identities people
being spotlit how did that feel to
really make your mark on this show in
that way goodness making my mark on this
show in that way you know it wasn't and
it wasn't just on this show it was on
such a large scale that I feel like I've
made a difference in some people's lives
and I could not be more thankful to have
inspired even one person to be them true
selves to feel confident in the skin
there and or to even create something
beautiful and fantastic and to put it on
a stage you know yes that's all I've
ever wanted to do inspire you put
everything on the stage and how does it
feel looking at who went home tonight
were you surprised by who ended up
getting sent home we were the same ones
in the bottom from last week that's all
I can say you know what does that make
you think all I can say is that we did
our very best we did everything that we
could on that stage and if America
didn't think it was enough that's
perfectly fine because we're gonna come
back and we are gonna prove ourselves to
anyone and everyone who ever doubted us
last question can you tell like where
did this come from this dress is amazing
oh gosh American Idol wardrobe is
amazing they had this was custom-made
for me all of this so thank you thank
you this was custom made and I
appreciate everything they've done for
me to make me look as best as possible
what will be one thing you take away
that you learned from Katy Perry
oh gosh Katy Perry has taught me so much
that she believes in me and to stay
strong to never doubt Who I am
believed that you know at the very
beginning they've said multiple times
they weren't sure how this was going to
go but they believed that I'm doing
exactly what I need to do and at exactly
the right time and that's something that
I'm gonna take with me and keep running
with
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]